c'est pour moi politique ça rime avec
éthique et quand on est ministre on doit
être à 100% à sa tâche si on veut être
candidat et personne ne peut lui donner
la légitimité à présenter sa candidature
il faut en tirer les conséquences et
partir pour qui un autre ministre qui
puisse être à 100% à redresser
l'économie internet et showman voilà
donc soit il met en sommeil sur sa
formation politique et ses levées de
fonds et il revient à 100% à bercy soit
ils en tirent les conséquences vous
savez pour moi la modernité en politique
ce n est pas représenté par emmanuel
macron alors si vous me disiez qui je
serai très gêné par le faire mais je
vais vous le dire quand même et français
savent que je suis proche d'elle
mais c'est plutôt anne hidalgo et ce
qu'elle fait à la mairie de paris et son
éthique aussi parce qu'elle elle dit moi
je suis maire de paris les parisiens -
élu pour être maire de paris et donc je
serai pas candidate à la présidentielle
de 2017
la prochaine c'est la modernité au pays
et elles travaillent avec le nouveau
maire de londres et elle va
travailler avec les maires des plus
grandes villes pour essayer de faire
avancer nos idées pour essayer de faire
vivre les algues ont écouté ça c'est
parce qu'on porte parole mais je voulais
juste vous à l'éclairer je voulais juste
éclairé à travers sable pour moi ce
qu'est la vraie modernité en politique